In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion, for June 20th, on which we commemorate the Holy Hyromarter
Methodios of Patara, Bishop of Olympus.
Consecrated to God from childhood, Saint Methodios became an instrument chosen by grace and was
consecrated as Bishop of Patara, or rather Olympus, in Licia.
Renowned for his vast philosophical culture and his zeal in regard to the truth of the Gospel,
he traveled from millet to Patara to participate in a discussion on the dogma of the resurrection.
From there he visited the principal towns of Licia and Pamphilia, and even journeyed to more
distant parts to defend the true faith against the pagan philosophers.
In reply to Plato's praise of Eros and claim that it was possible to be raised from love
of bodies to love of intelligible realities, Saint Methodios composed an admirable Apologia
on virginity and on the Christian life of virtue, called the banquet of the Ten Virgins.
He presented his work in the Platonic manner as a dialogue which took place in the garden
of Dame Virtue, sister of philosophy which was planted in the east, as in paradise in the
course of which each virgin gave in turn a nulogy of virginity.
Marcelo, the first praised virginity as a virtue which exercised on earth, made the chariot
of the soul ascend to heaven and led to incorruptibility and the likeness of God through the imitation
of Christ, the virgin par excellence.
It revealed, she added, the goal of the pedagogy which God used to lead humanity towards perfection
First of all, permitting incestuous unions, then polygamy which was to give way to chastity
in a monogamous marriage and finally virginity.
Theo Filia, then intervened to make it clear that marriage should not therefore be held
in disdain, saying, if honey is sweeter than other foods, it does not mean that they are
bitter.
The church is like a garden containing all sorts of flowers, some are the flowers of virginity,
others of procreation and others flowers of chastity.
When she had finished her intervention, all the other virgins applauded in order to express
their esteem for marriage.
Filia was the third to speak.
She said that, if the union of a man and a woman is a symbol of the union of Christ and
his church, virginity is a spiritual marriage which truly accomplishes this great mystery
of the union of the soul with its bridegroom, and she added that, if marriage was granted
to human beings by concession because of sin, virginity was a gift of God.
Theopatra developed this proposition by stating that nothing was more helpful to the restoration
of the life of paradise and to reconciliation with God than a chaste life.
Cassia then declared that, in order to be truly worthy of this name, virgins must keep
themselves entirely pure by the consecration to God of all the movements of the body
and soul, and that to bodily chastity must be added that of the mouth, the eyes, the ears,
the smell, the touch, and above all the heart, which wholly turned towards the Lord is no longer
concerned for anything worldly and no longer finds itself under the impulse of anger or vanity.
Agatha used the parable of the ten virgins to show that virginity must be preserved with
watchfulness from the assaults of corruption.
Then the word was given to Priscilla, who returning to the theological aspect of the question
declared that the flesh of Christ is the first bride that the word has assumed in order to
establish it like a queen at the right hand of the Father, and that all virgins therefore
become its followers. She praised virginity as superior to martyrdom, for it consists not
in facing trial for a brief moment, but in enduring the assaults of concupacence throughout
one's life. Then came the turn of Tecla, a virgin admired by the others for her knowledge
of philosophy, both human and divine. She gave the longest speech, and particularly praised
virginity, parthenia, by means of an etymological deduction suggesting that it came from, at
God's side, Parathéon, and that it gave the soul wings to lead a life like that of the
angels in heaven, while still on earth.
The discussion, having been completed by Titiana and Domina, who both developed allegorical interpretations
of the Old Testament, Dame Virtue took up the word to conclude, saying that virginity cannot
be simply limited to the idea of sexual continents, but that it implies a total consecration to
God of all one's movements, of spirit, and the senses. And with this word, she awarded
the crown to Tecla. The latter began to entone a rousing hymn in honor of virginity, while
the other virgins, forming a dancing choir, replied with the refrain. I will keep myself
pure for thee, O my bridegroom, and I will come to meet thee, holding a lighted torch.
During his travels, Saint Methodios opposed the nostics and other heretics who disdained
the body and the sensible creation, and showed that nothing evil has been created by God.
But he was above all the first to detect the errors of origin and to fight against his doctrine
on the pre-existence of souls, and their fall into bodies as into a prison, a concept that
resulted in the denial of the resurrection of the body.
After having labored mightily for the truth, Saint Methodios was beheaded at Calcy's in
Syria, probably in about 311 during the persecution under Licinius. Through the prayers of our holy
fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us, and save us.